hey everybody it's mike from order flows
and you know i'm shooting this video
it's sunday night it's labor day weekend
september 4th you know it's just after
around seven o'clock at night and i just
want to follow up on
the talking about order flow imbalances
you know yesterday i put out a video
talking about stacked imbalances and how
the market has memory around those areas
and what i will be talking about today
is just sort of follow up on it and
start looking at the market when there
are imbalances
and they're not stacked okay so there
might be you know in a bar that might be
two or three imbalances now the thing
with imbalances right again i explained
that yesterday it's it's the difference
between um
the aggressive buying and aggressive
selling in the two-way auction by over a
certain percentage right usually it's
four to one and in today's example i'm
using four to one that's that's the base
that i use always um again it's up to
you if you want to use four to one some
people use three to one some people use
you know six to one some people use nine
to one you know or 987 percent to one um
but you know it's up to you you got to
find your sweet spot but again for most
traders four to one is fine so again
this is sunday night uh on the labor day
holiday you know and people are always
afraid of oh my gosh you know sunday
night you know there's no liquidity it's
actually there's very good liquidity you
know when i was
working at the banks you know at jp
morgan and training firms like cargill
you know sunday nights were pretty
active especially if if friday was a uh
very active session obviously this past
friday was you know the the real money
is is still trading right people are
still watching this market you know
hedge funds have 24-hour trading desks
and you know they're watching what
happens on the open and and they're
reacting accordingly
so what i'll talk about there is go back
to the open of uh this session sunday
night five o'clock
chicago time and you know 1400 contracts
trade you got a nice strong negative
delta
you got you know minus 243 contracts
then markets started making a new low
for the first three minutes
it looked like it was going to
potentially start to rally you know we
had this one bar here it had zero delta
now people sometimes think oh i got zero
delta that must mean something no it's
really just a coincidence you know this
is a time based chart i'm looking at a
one minute chart and it just so happened
that when that one minute closed
delta was at zero right if there was an
extra nanosecond it might have been
a negative delta of minus three or you
know three more seconds it might have
been a positive delta of
plus 20. you know it's a difference of
basically one trade that it just the
time just cut off right so it just ended
and then right after that you got a nice
strong delta you got a nice stacked
buying imbalance right but
even though it's a stack mine and
balance the volumes are kind of light
you know 6 19 24 you know during the day
session
you by put a zero behind that um you're
gonna get a lot more volume the volume
that happens you know in the evening
session from the reopen up until um you
know 7 am chicago time
is about a not even a third of the whole
day's volume so you know you got to take
that into account when you're analyzing
volume you can't just say well you know
there's no volume here well there is
volume it's just not as strong as what
you see during the day
and you got a nice stack buying a
balance right that's a sign of
aggressive buyers coming into the market
right you got the positive delta of 83
stack buying and balance okay hey meal
maybe we can rally back up right we're
just coming up to the opening price the
opening price was 38.29
and we're rallying back up to that area
but then what happens nothing it doesn't
get that one further tick right up to
the open at 29 only gets up to 28 and
three quarters
and just goes inside on you right i
don't say it goes sideways it just you
know just sort of retraces the previous
bar and then what happens more selling
comes in and what time did it come in it
came about five minutes after the open
now
you know the way
a lot of traders
think on you know when the markets
reopen on sunday night is they want to
give it a chance to
settle down right i mean it's not like
it's going to be
trading gangbusters you know the way it
does on you know when a number comes out
but you know people want to sort of
let the market get its footing sort of
figure out which way it's going to go
and literally after five bars after five
minutes the aggressive selling comes in
right guess nice stack selling and
balance
it just gets whacked down here right you
can see the zeros right there's 3 19 2
7 14
23 25
25 38
82 56 you know 20. but on this side it's
zero zero zero zero zero one somebody
came in and just whacked it down
literally right when this bar opened
right right after five minutes of
trading sellers just came in whacked it
down whacked it down from what is that
27 and a half down to
you know down to 26 and even lower what
was interesting is you know it just
swept through that market that's left
that stack selling and balance
and even down at the bottom you got a
couple more selling imbalances right you
made that new low obviously a nice
strong negative delta
what's the direction telling you well
the direction's telling you to the
downside right and market makes new lows
makes new lows notice on this next bar
there's one buying imbalance okay
nothing special it's still got negative
delta the bar
it's a small tiny up bar but you know
it's close to unchanged on where the bar
opened and closed then the next bar big
down bar again right more selling
imbalances so
this bar here got like what is that
seven selling imbalances one binding
balance another two cell in a bounce
next bar another two sauna balance
no selling it balances no buying
imbalances now here you got a
a sign of potentially maybe this market
can bounce right what do we got we got
divergence we got a new low with
positive delta we got a order flow ratio
a bullish one but the next bar doesn't
go any higher just makes a new low
it starts to come back up here more
buying imbalances too okay positive
delta so maybe
it looks like this market can start to
rally
but what is the market telling you it's
not ready to rally it only goes one tick
higher
over the next two bars right it goes the
high of this bar is 22 and a quarter i
this bar is 22 and a half point of
controls are lined up at 22 and a
quarter
okay and and i talked about this a few
days ago
right this is a potential resistance
area right especially if the market were
to come back to it right if you were to
draw this line here
i i want to obviously this is going to
be resistance mark it's staying under
and you just see how it's just hanging
around here right comes right back up to
that just sort of hangs around but i'll
get to that in a minute
but anyway i don't want to digress here
more selling it balances in this bar so
since that big push down after the five
minutes after the market's settled down
you're seeing mostly selling imbalances
what do you think the market's trying to
tell you well
there's more selling
obviously um
you know people want to try and find
arguments for buying and there has
really hasn't been
many arguments for buying right there's
maybe one argument in here with these
two green candles but you can't go any
higher so
what do you think is going to happen if
it's not going higher it's going to go
lower
more solenoid balances come in right one
two three four five cell and balances
market makes a new low
one two three selling it balances right
we're at the low of the day
you know 39 15 and a quarter
got negative delta at the low
2 bar strong negative delta now these
are strong relative to this time period
minus 201 minus 211 and then what
happens goes inside inside inside
inside four inside bars of this big bar
down
but after the first bar right this green
bar going inside that's a sign that
potentially the move is over right i
always talk about you know you want to
be looking for signs of potentially the
market movement is over right we did
have a sell-off from you know 29 all the
way down to 15 and a quarter and then
now the market is starting to go inside
on you
right notice over here you have a big
dart bar down and you went inside inside
and just sort of went sideways
starting to see the same thing shape up
here now here you're seeing small deltas
19 minus 5 minus 9. it's not really much
direction going on
again you're getting two point controls
here lined up on these two green bars
i'll just move this line down
okay well you know maybe all right you
got to be thinking i got three green
bars up i got these pointed controls
lined up here
i see one buying imbalance okay it's
nothing to get excited about just one
binary balance
that's nothing two against 12
that's not big volume small deltas minus
five minus nine maybe
what the market is telling you is that
it it's
putting in a base right you don't have
big directional trade yet coming in but
you're starting to see point of controls
lined up and then you want to see if the
market's going to come back what's going
to happen comes right back down
three bars later
right fourth bar again it's just sort of
hanging there doesn't really break down
into the low we put this new point of
control right down here at 16 and a
quarter just hanging around
okay so maybe this could potentially be
a support area down here we're looking
at you know somewhere between you know
this point of control here
this one here at uh
16 yeah obviously you got these at 16
and three quarters
market starts going up more selling and
balances here gotta stack selling and
balance but it's small
eight against one ten against one zero
against six
okay you know i i'd like it to be a
little bit stronger just no counter
trade you know maybe this is a big order
somebody sold 25 contracts
okay nothing happened market came right
back up
again another selling stack selling and
balance eight against two seven against
one ten against one
market didn't trade lower but it's still
you know i know i got this area here
potential support
so i got a stack sound and balance being
drawn out up here
okay which market did come back to and
just went sideways on you
but what are you seeing in this area
here again nothing special in the deltas
no really big numbers one way or the
other this one had minus 75 this one had
minus 101 but other than that
it's fairly
evenly spread out now granted it's
sunday night on a holiday
the volumes aren't that strong
but nevertheless i mean you're seeing
four
zero 13 16 15 you know three three three
two
but as you get in here all right it's a
little hard to see because the deltas
aren't really giving you much
small deltas but you're starting to see
you know buying and balancing selling
balance but buying balance buying and
balance mining balance starting to see
almost every bars is sort of kicking off
buying imbalances right one two three
four five
six
okay seven eight you know you're getting
a lot more buying imbalances than
selling imbalances okay so that's a clue
well there's some a little bit slightly
more aggressive buying than aggressive
selling and if you're looking at the
deltas delta's at this point honestly
isn't really giving you much to go off
of because the deltas are just too small
okay
and you're sort of going sideways this
level down here is holding we took out
this stacked selling and balance i do
know i have this stack selling a balance
from up here from earlier right this is
that one right after the open right in
here at the
505 up here at 26 and then
what happens you get this one bar here
two selling imbalances and then it snaps
right back stack buying a balance right
in here 12 28 35 24 even a couple more
buying and balances
all of a sudden you know it's like the
market is just like flatlining you know
you you see those
those medical shows the guys
um you know they're like doing the cpr
he's like flatlining and then all of a
sudden you know the hard kicks got the
heartbeat comes in
right and you get that stacked buying
and balance
delta jumps 142. right you don't see
anything anything over 100 you know
since that that low was made down here
when it was minus 200 okay now you got a
sign of life
pay attention well then what else do you
see okay so now i know i have this zone
being drawn out next bar is up hasn't
come back into it next bar couple more
buying and balances next bar two more
buying imbalances nice strong delta 136.
next bar buying a balance buying a
balance now you're coming into this area
where you had that stack selling a
balance and this is something you got to
watch for you know areas where you had
strong aggressive selling before
you want to watch is that selling going
to still be there
or not
and more importantly if it's an area
where you had strong aggressive selling
earlier and now you're seeing strong
aggressive buying come in at that same
level
that's an important clue those are good
trades to take
and what do you have you have stacks
selling a balance from earlier the zone
being drawn out and into that area into
that resistance you got nice strong
aggressive buying nice stack buying and
balancing here and you go higher right
you finally take out the opening price
right up here at 29
okay then you sort of go sideways
another stack buying and balance
right and then as you go up making new
highs more buying and balances more
buying and balances as you're making new
highs right it's you know i'm making
this video it's just after seven o'clock
we made this new high up here at what is
that 38 that well the high is 38 three
quarters but you know we made a high up
here at the 38th
we have this area in here right a stack
buying a balance with the zone being
drawn out got stacked selling a balance
just coming in right before that area
i would like it more if that selling it
balances was here i'd be
looking to be more bearish but it's an
area where you had stacked aggressive
buying earlier and all of a sudden you
got stacked aggressive selling
i wouldn't be surprised to see this
market sell off from this area here at
34 33 and a half at least come down to
you know i mean it's the night session
so the moves aren't going to be as
as sweet as you would see during the day
but you know at this point when i'm
making this video you know put a gun to
my head take a short yeah definitely got
to be short you know we got a stack
selling a balance up here i got a
potential resistance here we got through
this one
we threw this um
support
and it's sort of coming in right around
that same level so yeah i'd definitely
be short but really the trade to take is
back here right when this stack buying a
balance came in out of nowhere
right what had this market been doing
this is came in at eight eight six 18
for the last
gosh going all the way back here to just
after that low has been made the low was
done at 5 18.
for almost an hour the market is is
basically going sideways right i mean
you had to stack selling a balance
market did nothing
all right you get in here you got to
stack buying a balance and now you're
starting to see the market start to
rally okay so that's your sign to take
of direction i don't say take the trade
but you know that's a trade that i would
take after a market has been going
sideways for so long and you see
something a sign of life
in in the form of imbalances and
definitely in the form of stacked
imbalances
that's nice to see right that's that's
the direction you want to go now the
only spanner in the works is this bar
here right preceding the the stack
buying it balances
you've got the um two selling imbalances
all right but the market obviously
didn't go any lower
um yeah i i would have it would look a
lot nicer
if it didn't have that
little aggressive selling before it came
around but who knows right maybe these
guys that were selling it in here we're
trying to
get it to break down and then also now
they gotta start covering it so it's
gonna add more fuel to the fire but
other than that you know really after
you see that stack buying and balance
come in and it's holding right we're not
retracing back into it the trade is to
the upside i do know i got some
resistance up here at you know the 26
area 26 and a quarter with the stack
selling a balance earlier but then
seeing this
stack minor balance come in at that same
area it makes me feel more confident on
the trade that it's going to
at least you know target of 29 the
opening price which was acting a bit as
resistance earlier and once you get past
that all right another stack buying and
balance you know it's just up to
new highs so you know right now as we're
talking you know markets coming back
down didn't get back down to what is
that 30 didn't quite get back down to 29
so anyway guys you know i hope you can
start to think more about uh you know
analyzing imbalances it's not just one
imbalance that you're trying to analyze
you got to put it in context with you
know are there other imbalances in the
bar what about previous bars you know
has it shifted from mostly selling and
balances over the last several bars just
to buying imbalances over the next
several bars things like that right
don't just take it in isolation and say
well i got one bar with um
three buying imbalances like i get long
right try and put it in context with
what's been happening
so again you know i hope you appreciate
this video be sure to like it and
subscribe to it and i'll be posting
videos a little bit more regularly now
that i've got more time so thanks
everyone bye-bye